foreign
the British economy is in crisis
the government has lost control of the
British economy in his mini budget
Britain's new Chancellor quasi-courteng
announced 45 billion pounds of unfunded
tax cuts causing the pound to plummet
the British pound has fallen to its
lowest level ever against the US dollar
the city of London woke up to a currency
crisis shocking the markets and leading
the bank of England to intervene the
bank of England has said that it will
buy as many long-dated government bonds
as required the international monetary
fund has slammed the government's plan
how bad is this and is there worse to
come as the markets rejected carsonomics
prime minister
our Britain economics editor Samaya
Keynes explains what's happening
the past week has been a Monumental week
for the British economy the government
announced regulatory reforms and also
tax cuts income tax cuts scrapping a
planned increase in corporation tax
changes to Bankers bonuses I think it's
the understatement of the century to say
that this went down extremely badly The
Fallout has been extraordinarily
embarrassing for a government that is
only a few weeks old there are really
big questions about the seriousness of
the government's handle on the public
finances and the extent to which it's in
control but the government doesn't
operate in a vacuum it looks like the
bank of England is going to respond to
this fiscal statement by raising
interest rates even more aggressively
than it was planning before that means
more expensive mortgages for households
that means house prices potentially
falling and it generally means depressed
demand and potentially a recession
fixing all of this restoring credibility
would require an astonishing U-turn it
would require reversing some of the tax
cuts the government has said that it
will publish its fiscal rules alongside
an independent forecast of the public
finances in late November that needs to
happen sooner now neither of those look
like they're going to happen what's more
likely is that the government is going
to ask departments to find efficiency
savings that means Cuts it's been
reported that they may be considering
real terms Cuts in benefits that will be
politically extraordinarily difficult
when they've just announced tax cuts for
the richest the political difficulty of
restoring credibility and and giving
this sense to International investors
that things are under control is just
really really difficult right now all of
this is happening in a broader economic
context of course borrowing costs to
governments arising around the world
Britain is not the only one by any means
but the increase in its borrowing costs
has been remarkably large there is a
Britain specific component here it's not
right to say that this is just as part
of a general Trend it is also true
though that if those problems are fixed
borrowing costs for the government would
still be rising in general the economic
environment is just becoming more
hostile it's becoming more hostile to
governments making mistakes and the
British government is feeling the pain
of that
thank you for watching to read more of
our coverage of the British economy
click the link and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]